well my talk of the table is about
actress and singer Rita Wilson she is a
force on camera and behind the scenes
she has starred in dozens of films
produced box-office hits like My Big Fat
Greek Wedding love that Mamma Mia love
that too Wilson has also released four
studio albums and she's toured the world
she's been busy performing her music on
stages from the Sydney Opera House to
the Grand Ole Opry now she's out with
something that's a haunting new song
it's called everybody cries its featured
in the new movie the outpost about a
battle in Afghanistan everybody cries
everybody dies it's the truth and make
sense one
it's the center of our Sun as we take
the lonely path
on the road
[Laughter]
oh boy Rita Wilson joins us now redock
it's really good to see you there's a
line in the song that goes and you
co-wrote a song there will be the last
nice to see you who will be the last to
remain when there's only God when
there's only God in pain that's the line
that got to me I think the song is
haunting and it's based on the movie the
outpost based on a book by Jake Tapper
which is a true story so put it in
perspective with it for us about why
this song worked so well with this movie
well you know that it's based on a true
battle in Afghanistan where eight
servicemen lost their lives and at the
same time the director of the film Rob
Lurie lost his son and I think he was
compelled to sort of have this idea that
there would be a song in the movie that
the soldiers could sing and I think he
was very very connected to all of that
when he was making the movie it happened
while he was making though V which is
absolutely tragic a parent's worst
nightmare basically but the song is used
in the movie a couple of times and also
at the end credits of the movie over the
faces of the actual servicemen who lost
their lives in that battle but I'm
thinking about you reader Wilson you've
got a lot going on you've got three
songs out at the same time
everybody's cries where is my country
song and when this is over where's my
country song has been described as a
love letter to women tell us about that
one I love the lyrics of this too well
you and I Gail share a love of country
music that is definite right and you
know I sent you something the other day
but
it's really to me in in country music I
think sometimes females and women are
idealized and I started looking at all
the women that I know that are single
parents or women like my mom who raised
kids and had a family but didn't ever
have a traditional job and then I also
was thinking about the women that we
come in contact with all the time and
sometimes we see and sometimes we don't
see those are the women behind the
scenes women who might work in factories
or warehouses or agriculture or any of
that so to me I started thinking about
those women and sometimes they don't get
the spotlight shown on them in the way
that I think is really important because
without women like that where would we
be you know I mean everybody has to be
valued and yeah it has to be appreciated
so many of the frontline workers are
women too so that is very very important
so the thing this is what I was really
excited about though reading it's the
latest one it's called when this is over
with you and Jimmy Allen who I just
recently I'm just late to the Jimmy
Allen party really like him but I know
he is he is I mean he's one of the few
black people in country music so he
caught my eye with that and then I heard
his voice and he had I heard his voice
before I even knew who he was or what
color he was I just responded because he
was so good and he reached out to me to
participate on this song and mmin honor
because I was already a fan and I think
I believe that the album is the number
one on country are getting to be number
one in the country or something but it's
doing really well and he has a number
black artists on the album - Charlie
pride is on there Darius Rucker a young
artist Mickey Gaytan female artist that
I love and young Christian weeks we just
are we just had rehearsal recently toran
Welles Mickey because the thing about
this song yeah we just had her on I
don't know if it's about kovat or if
it's just going through hard times I
said one lyric says I hope these hard
times make me better not just older when
this is over when we were introducing
you earlier Rita we said actress yeah
actress singer Kol bid survivor so I
really want to bring people up to date
about how you're feeling because you've
been through it well thank ya Mac Ovid
survivor
yes I'm very very very very happy and
very healthy thankfully I think that
part of the thing that I feel so
grateful for is that we still have
antibodies we are part of a study at
UCLA so we are giving our blood and
they're testing it and what we I have
learned is that even though we have
antibodies that they will diminish over
time so you don't know if you're going
to be contagious again or you can even
get the virus again there's still so
much to figure out but right now we're
still kind of we have some immunities
and we're doing okay and we still
practice what we would practice wearing
a mask even though we are maybe safer
than the general public I just think
it's important to yeah to do it because
we really don't know there's so much we
don't know yeah you know Tom waiting the
other day he was on Stephen Colbert
because I really want you I really want
to get your take on the mass wearing you
know it has become such a political
issue such a hot button potato in this
country which just drives me nuts
because the evidence shows that it
clearly saves lives but you hear people
say you can't tell me what to do it's
not my right and or that or this is a
thing Rita that the mask is
uncomfortable what do you say to that as
someone who's been through kovat it
knows what it can do well
I say that I don't understand why
something that's so easy to do has
become an issue or something that people
are coming up against to me it's sort of
like brushing your teeth twice a day is
good for your health and we do that so
why wouldn't you wear a mask because
it's good for your health it just
doesn't make sense
but yeah you know what I mean and
someone gets sick and what you know the
mask is uncomfortable but you know what
else is uncomfortable dying so let me
ask you this there's a national song
that says would you still need me will
you still feed me when I'm sixty-four
Tom Hanks the other day did a video
about I'm 64 will you still need him
will you still feed him now that he's 64
well I think he's 64 in 10 days old or
something like that I don't know what
the date is today but yeah I still so
far when I looked at my watch this
morning I still loved him and needed him
and I will I will feed him because soon
it's breakfast time
tell them we said hey congratulations
Rita congratulations thank you thank you
thank you thanks to everyone for
listening to the music too I really
appreciate it